Hélène buzetti à la Gaston gay Christian
Dufour bonsoir bonsoir c'est vrai que
l'environnement médiatique n'est
absolument pas le même ici il faut quand
même le souligner
c'est très particulier ceux qui
connaissent pas les réseaux cablés c'est
vraiment des c'est presque des partis
politiques parce que les partis
politiques
ne vous inquiétez pas Hélène je vous
envoie pas là-dessus mais sur le 3 je
vous voyais réagir qu'est-ce qui va
qu'est-ce qui est où il s'envole
troisième lien je vous fais entendre
Eric dum qui comme prévu elle n'est pas
lâcher le morceau sur cette histoire là
on écoute
on va faire un paquet d'actions
concrètes ici dans l'appeler tri pour
que la pression soit insoutenable et qui
récupère fasse la seule chose honorable
qui lui reste à faire c'est à dire
respecter sa parole et démissionner et
on va être intrétable on va on va être
sur toutes les tribunes on va être
partout on va être dans le porte-à-porte
on va envoyer des dépliants on va être à
l'épicerie au centre d'achat vous allez
nous voir partout on va faire de
l'affichage on va tout faire pour que
ericare soit forcé de démissionner
il y a une pétition qu'ils ont lancé
donc il y a quelques jours il y a 5600
personnes qui ont signé je crois déjà la
pétition
ericaire doit se dire là je vais avoir
ce caillou dans mon soulier quelques
semaines avec
ça lui permet de revenir dans les médias
iriduels avec une cause qu'il aime le
troisième lien en plus c'est une
séquence on l'appelle tri ou le Parti
conservateur avait fait d'assez pas aux
résultats on peut passer que si ericaire
démissionne et qu'un élection partielle
et qui rique du M6 présente il a des
chances de l'emporter donc oui c'est
c'est tout à fait bon jeu de la part de
rituels de mettre la pression sur
érecteur ceci dit il y a pas beaucoup il
y a pas de mécanisme vraiment pour le
forcer à démissionner même la pétition
qu'on met en ligne on pourra pas la
déposer à l'Assemblée nationale ça prend
un député pour le déposer à l'Assemblée
nationale cette pétition là je sais pas
si on va se trouver un parrain dans un
autre parti politique pour le faire on
peut penser qu'à la CAQ on va pas
parrainer la pétition des rituels donc
il y a pas de mécanisme de révocation le
Parti québécois en proposant mais bon on
s'entend que ça sera pas créé à court
terme donc ce n'est qu'une pression
politique pour espérer faire
démissionner rituels et que le Parti
conservateur en profite mais honnêtement
quand on s'est peinturé dans le coin au
point des recettes jusqu'à la dernière
goutte de sang mettons que un moment
donné il y a quelqu'un qui rappelle ses
paroles puis j'aurais fait probablement
la même chose à la place d'Eric Duval
c'est drôle parce que il est la
situation objective fait qu'il est
encore le paratonnerre de cette histoire
là il l'avait été dans l'histoire du de
la SAAQ
Hélène et ça ça tombe sur lui parce
qu'il est allé loin effectivement en
disant oui oui gardez le thème comme il
avait dit je vais démissionner oui et
puis c'est lui et sa conscience en bout
de piste là ce qu'il est capable de
vivre avec lui-même mais et je comprends
tout à fait ce que Éric Duhem fait parce
que effectivement il est le plus grand
perd dans cette situation je le répète
si la carte avait eu le courage de
reculer juste avant l'élection ou
pendant l'élection ça aurait
probablement donné suffisamment de
munitions aux parties conservateurs de
Monsieur Duhem pour faire peut-être et
lire un deux voire même trois députés et
faire cette fameuse entrée à l'Assemblée
nationale qui n'a pas été possible
ceci dit oui monsieur du monsieur care
et celui qui est allé plus loin comme
comme vous dites est devenu paratonnerre
mais il y a presque quelque chose d'un
peu injuste ou un grand pour lui parce
que il n'est pas le seul dans ce bateau
là c'est toute la CAQ ce sont les 90
députés kakis il y a madame Biron il y a
Monsieur Draguignan tout plein d'autres
promesses
alors un moment donné on peut pas non
plus demander à un gouvernement
entièrement de démissionner parce qu'il
n'a pas rempli sa promesse
c'est effectivement choquant parce que
les citoyens ont l'impression que ça a
été fait rouler mais en même temps il
faut quand même garder à l'esprit c'est
important de dire pour pas trop
alimenter non plus 6000 cynisme
électorale même si je comprends que dans
cette situation là c'est difficile de
rester zen que le
polymètre d'université Laval qui teste
les promesses électorales les
gouvernements nous arrivent autant pour
monsieur Legault que Monsieur Trudeau a
à 80% des promesses électorales qui sont
tenues à peu près 20% qui ne le sont pas
qui sont rompus alors c'est frustrant
mais ce n'est quand même pas la majorité
des promesses qui finissent comme ça au
dépotoir électoral vous êtes bonne de
rappeler ça effectivement
la bonté le vrai sens du mot la bonté
Christian Dufour quand même celle-là
elle était spectaculaire la promesse le
d'où le d'où le contexte politique de la
région de Québec qui a pas fini de
bouillonner ouais c'est une chose que de
dire à partir de Montréal comme je l'ai
fait la semaine passée que la décision
de la carte pas seulement à Québec mais
moi je reviens de ces jours de trois
jours à Québec et j'étais estomac c'est
énorme à Québec cette affaire lol ça
passe pas du tout c'est vécu comme une
trahison même par des gens qui
contestaient le troisième lien c'est la
grande région de Québec il faut juste
Quebec évidemment c'est les visser la
base c'est c'est belle chasse j'aurais
même que l'aspect identitaire
et pour Monsieur Legros c'est un grand
problème moi la semaine prochaine je me
disais il commence peut-être à se
désalouser je me demande c'est pas plus
enlisée qu'avant sur l'extables la
pandémie moi j'ai l'impression que c'est
le plus gros problème auquel le
gouvernement le goût est confronté
depuis qu'il est là parce que ça touche
au cœur de ce qu'il est d'abord c'est un
château fort cakiste la grande région de
Québec donc vraiment un sentiment moi ça
me prouve frappé je vois au Québec à
quel point ça motif il y avait une
colère très très forte poser son cocus
on sait que dans notre régime
parlementaire de type britannique le
premier c'est comme Roy élu quelque part
si tu as pas la fin de tout le monde
dans la mesure où il garde le contrôle
la confiance du caucus ils sont 90
députés et puisqu'on reproche entre
autres monsieur le Gaulle c'est de pas
avoir averti les gens de pas avoir
averti les principaux responsables qui
ont perdu la face et un autre chose
aussi en fait qui me frappé c'est
vraiment les bouts de critiques à
l'égard des gens d'or de Montréal les
commentateurs en dehors de Montréal et
entre Madame Valérie plante la mairesse
de Montréal tu peux faire le meilleur de
carrière en émettant très vite un tweet
dans lequel elle se félicitait de cette
décision là donc les gens disent
qu'est-ce qu'elle a à dire là-dedans
donc moi c'est sûr que je veux dire
c'est que c'est énorme bon mais et
d'ailleurs Alex il y aura un caucus
spécial demain des députés de monsieur
Legault de la région de Québec ou
monsieur Lego va plaider va s'expliquer
va écouter j'imagine on va faire de
l'écoute active
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui ont
besoin de ventiler les électeurs qui
comprennent pas trop ce qui s'est passé
de l'espèce de tour de magie et je
j'ouvre une dernière parenthèse il faut
dire que le prétexte donné donc les
données ont changé passe par des MI les
changements sont quand même mineurs on
pourrait faire on aurait pu faire le
plaidoyer deux ans que ça avait pas de
bon sens ce projet-là non plus
la lumière majeure donc la conférence de
presse seul de Geneviève Guilbaud je lui
dis c'est produit en aussi à huis clos
ou le mardi matin alors de cette
rencontre là alors là le Premier
ministre là il y a pas vraiment pris la
balle au bon ça c'est pas expliqué là il
va le faire demain tenter d'apaiser les
grogne leur dit que il reste 3 ans et
demi avant une élection on a encore le
temps de corriger ça voici les données
dès lors on peut faire un projet de
transport collectif on y croit mais il y
a laissé une semaine de battements qui
font en sorte que sur le terrain les
députés se sont fait chauffer les
oreilles puis là ils sont gonflés à bloc
alors ça j'aimerais ça un petit oiseau
là demain sur le bord de la fenêtre du
bureau du premier ministre pour entendre
ce qui va se dire dans ce dans ses
dragons là Hélène vous disiez tout à
l'heure c'est parce que c'est un peu
facile puis je parlais de j'ai utilisé
l'expression paratonnerre c'est un peu
facile de de d'isoler équerre puis de
mettre le bon aidant et puis bon
cette promesse là était tellement
existentielle et importante que la
personne qui doit s'expliquer auprès des
comme auprès des gens de Québec pour
près du caucus c'est le premier ministre
lui-même Hélène il y a absolument au nom
de son gouvernement et c'est pour ça que
j'insiste je vous dites j'ai fait preuve
de beauté et j'accepte mais je veux pas
avoir la trop bonne non plus parce que
oui le gouvernement offre louer les
électeurs j'abands tout à fait dans le
sens d'aller quand et de quand vous
disiez tout à l'heure que les données
ont pas vraiment changé de manière
significative il y avait toutes sortes
d'éléments qui se sont qui se sont
ajoutés combinés et qui bon prise
ensemble faisait en sorte que il
devenait de plus en plus clair que ce
projet-là ne pourrait pas aller de la
vente quoi dans la forme qui nous avait
été présentée à l'origine et écoutez on
est tout de suite après l'élection là ça
fait pas tellement longtemps alors moi
je n'y crois pas que que on n'aurait pas
pu faire exactement la même annonce au
mois de juillet au mois d'août dernier
mais on l'a pas fait pour des raisons
absolument évidentes parce que on
voulait garder la région au Québec et
donc non et normal que les gens de
Québec se sentent floués mais ceci dit
toute cette idée de d'un projet de loi
sur la révocation moi ça me fait
beaucoup penser à des idées réformistes
qu'on avait ici à Ottawa c'est un sujet
que mettait de l'avance Stockwell d il
avec 25 % des électeurs on renvoie un
député et on refait une élection bon il
était très bonne en théorie mais en
pratique quels sont les seuils pas juste
mathématiques mais quels sont les seuils
philosophiques et à partir duquel on
peut faire ça c'est quel sujet qu'on
peut dire qu'on les renvoie et ça crée
beaucoup d'instabilité aussi mais en
même temps peut-être l'exutoire est
nécessaire dans un grand dossier comme
celui-là Christian et même si je venais
de dire que la responsabilité ultime
revient au Premier ministre au bureau de
Premier ministre on imagine que si
Ricard demain disait j'ai réfléchi
effectivement j'avais dit que je m'en
allais je m'en vais et je vais me
représenter il y aurait quelque chose de
peut-être qui ferait du bien aux gens de
Québec peut-être pas je sais pas
moi je crois que je crois pas que le
gouvernement prévoyait une réaction
aussi négative au cœur de son château
fort je pense pas que ça attendait à ça
et c'est clair que ça aurait été sain et
positif si Eric Clerc pardon pour
sauvegarder son honneur pour sauvegarder
sa crédibilité avait démissionné je me
suis trompé j'assume la responsabilité
c'est ça notre système aussi quand on
parle de responsabilité ministère il y
en a un qui prend le blâme pour la gagne
pour les autres et qui se représente
dans une élection complémentaire mais
comment le dit tantôt le problème c'est
que ça ça va ouvrir un boulevard pour
que Eric duham fasse son entrée
triomphalement à l'Assemblée nationale
donc je pense pas que Monsieur le gauve
vouloir que ericaire démission ils sont
comme coincés pendant un autre élément
aussi j'en ai pas la semaine passée une
façon un peu humoristique mais là je le
dis de façon un peu plus sérieuse pour
notre société si on réalise l'enseigne
10 ans le cinéma les petites études sur
un an ou deux me projette comme ça c'est
un projet très long terme si on réalise
en 5 10 ans que le troisième lien c'est
un nécessaire
on va voir l'air fou pas mal comme
société dans notre incapacité de
réaliser des grands projets ça fait des
mois des années qu'on parle de ça tout
le monde a une opinion même pas des gens
ils connaissent rien les gens
d’endorment de Québec se sont beaucoup
embarqués dans le dossier et moi
là-dessus je comprends les gens le
Québec une commission technique avec des
experts puis des faits puis que
indépendamment de la joue de politique
puis qu'on décide si on a besoin puis ou
puis un pont c'est un peu ça que
beaucoup de gens disaient depuis des
années Christian aussi on veut des
études on veut des faits mais je trouve
qu'il y avait trop de monde que c'est
là-dedans
et on est revenu des experts au Québec
dans dans le fait de voir des obstacles
est-ce qu'on est encore capable de
réaliser des grands projets moi je suis
pas sûr du tout pierre paulièvre serait
un peu d'accord avec vous parce que lui
veut encore veut un troisième lien avec
des autos mais dis-moi si je suis
premier ministre du Canada Hélène je ne
vais pas mettre d'argent dans un
troisième lien où il y a que du
transport en commun je veux des voitures
mois d'utile il dit ils ont écouté les
World puis les chroniqueurs Google de
Montréal
il ne fait pas ça pour des raisons
électorales il a déjà toute la rive sud
de Québec bon peut-être qu'il pourrait
gagner les regagner puis devrais-je dire
les deux circonscriptions de Beauport
qui lui ont filé tes doigts mais c'est
près des sœurs et qui sont passés au
Bloc québécois mais il campe son
personnage politique il essaie de
démontrer qu'il est l'homme de la
banlieue l'homme des des villes
périphériques il n'est pas un vide un
homme du centre mais de centre-ville
pardon mais ce faisant je pense qu'il se
coupe peut-être d'un électorat potentiel
en campant comme ça son personnage de
manière aussi radicale oui Alex un peu
de caricatures aussi bon les gens de la
région Montréal ont le dollars mais pas
eux qui ont décidé que c'est que ce
projet-là ne n'irait pas de l'avant à
l'aide
de François Legault sur l'île de
Montréal donc le centre de gravité
de la c'est pas mal plus à Québec puis
dans l'Est du Québec donc
il y avait beaucoup de caricatures
là-dedans de Pierre
est-ce que ça va vraiment l'aider je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas c'est assez
tranché comme comme position là il est
en faveur de dépenser beaucoup beaucoup
de milliards de dollars pour un tunnel
très bien mais les commentateurs de
Montréal ont été très actifs dans ce
dossier là et c'est très mal vu à Québec
et je les comprends vous faites pas
partie de ça
on essaie d'avoir tous les points de vue
salut à bientôt au revoir